en 2006 jean luc mélenchon déclarait la
présidentielle n'est pas un concours de
beauté et martine aubry disait ceci la
politique n'est pas une affaire de
mensurations et pourtant c'est
exactement l'inversé que décrit françois
hourmant professeur de sciences
politiques dans son dernier essai
pouvoir et beauté aux éditions puf donc
l'apparence a pris une place éclatante
en politique selon lui mais ce phénomène
est refoulé ou alors minorés
bah ça parce que le
rck
les électeurs préféreraient les beaux
visages avec un et fin des grands yeux
des pommettes saillantes et aussi les
corps à tiroirs évidemment les
politiques ne sera visiblement donc il
exhibe ray dès que possible leur beauté
de plus en plus travailler un exemple
criant lord moi oui enfin de beauté en
exemple criant les photos de politiciens
à la plage en 1974 giscard s'exauce jean
mailhot à saint jean cap ferrat c'est
quoi comment ça va bouger mais ça va
très bien je me souviens j'étais petit
j'ai eu envie de faire pipi
j'ai pas mangé
tu peux aller faire pipi revenir non non
non non je reste
une étude réalisée en 2003 en finlande
dans le cadre d'élections parlementaires
a démontré que la beauté influencer le
choix des électeurs de près de 20% et
qu'est ce qui explique ce phénomène de
biens déjà le culte de la célébrité
auquel les politiciens n'échappe pas
aujourd'hui mais aussi l'électorat de
plus indécis dont qui s'accrochent à des
critères esthétiques plutôt qu'aux
critères politiques pour voter et puis
évidemment la montée en puissance des
images dans nos sociétés eric zemmour
rangs des gens iran les journalistes fou
iran la classe politique folle j'ai
entendu anne hidalgo lé traité de
guignol l'autre jour et je vois des
journalistes qui effectivement impôts
c'est le diable je peux pas vous dire
autre chose pour eux c'est le diable
tord ou à raison mais pour eux c'est le
diable moi je suis très frustré de café
moore avant pourquoi il veut vous
descendre savez tous les crétins la
fasciste pétainiste et depuis casey
moore on sait plus insulter
marine le pen myskina
je l'envoie elle me fait de la peine
maintenant c'est devenu ma raciste
préféré limiter
tout fait pour passer à la pauvre elle a
tout fait pour dédiaboliser repartie
elle a viré son père elle à changer le
nom du parti elle s'intéresse à des
domaines dont elle s'en bat les griots
c'est l'économie l'écologie elle
comprend rien
c'est dit ça a passé zemmour il arrive à
le presser les arabes 17%
elle était là derrière je l'avais dit en
premier mois nicolas sarkozy aurait
refusé il ya quelques années qu'un homme
politique devienne l'un de ses ministres
parce qu'ils le jugent le site trop laid
et d'ailleurs h c'est vrai en tout cas
oui et d'ailleurs quelques années plus
tard une étude universitaire prouver que
les électeurs de droite étaient beaucoup
plus sensible aux critères physiques que
les électeurs de gauche on part au
chirurgien cet après midi je vais
refaire ma poitrine parce que bas au
japon sa bonne bouille sa penderie bien
maintenant on peut s'appréhender mais
moi je suis un peut pas me faire manger
par terre mais bon c'était ton qui
louche elle était ton qu'il est jeune et
je vous remercie de faire encore preuve
de mépris et d'arrogance comme vous le
faites si souvent rien à mes choix ou
les petits mouchoirs il va pleurer non
il va pleurer après qui sait pas c'est
tout je vous ai fait beau je voudrais
faire un gros beaubourg merci merci
merci de faire preuve encore d'argos et
de montrer votre visage moi ça me va
très bien c'était tout ce que je voulais
produire
[Musique]
je vous dis avec plaisir
le candidat perdrait-il ses nerfs pas du
tout répondre ses soutiens comme le
président des amis d'eric zemmour ce
matin sur bfm gilles bouleau a voulu se
faire eric zemmour eric zemmour a montré
un calme olympiques
j'aurais olympiens ont chacun fait comme
il veut oui bonjour c'est michel oui
bonjour monsieur bonjour michel michel
vous allez être surpris mais ce n'est
pas une blague c'est julien courbet ne
sommes en direct sur rtl et sur m6
michel we voient leur bail au moins bons
mois au revoir au moins intégré notre
droit on peut pas raccrocher comme ça
sans rien dire un petit mot quand même
va te faire moi on est habitué à ça
nicolas en off branleuses un autre
ébranlé remarquerez ce point c'était les
deux neuf lettres très bien et y avait
pas mal de huit lettres oui non non
c'est admis parce qu'on est sur la même
même racine c'est pas le même sens quand
même
c'est vrai vous avez raison ariel
m16 connaissez mieux que moi
pas mieux hop hop
petit coquin va gérer un petit voyage en
martinique pourquoi pas si vous gagnez
des souches chez nous oui on y est déjà
allé avec ma femme et mes fait du ski
nautique et alors ça s'était bien passé
pour moi oui pour elle non pourquoi le
moniteur lui a dit qu'elle avait un
style pas le bon mais qu'elle avait un
style d'accord et elle logeait sais pas
si on peut le dire c'est pas dans les
yeux qu'elle l'apprécié ailleurs alors
excusez moi alors dans la bouche
les jambes écartées je veux pas savoir
par la compétition sportive la plus
spectaculaire de ces dernières 24 heures
s'est étirée
oui totalement une course de chaise de
bureau
compétition si sérieuse que physique à
un règlement strict ça se joue à
reculons vous imaginez bien qu'en
découvrant cette vidéo notre première
réaction a été mais quelle bande de
gamins immatures
[Applaudissements]
fabien suivre quelle est la différence
entre les deux chaises à chaleur de
montcuq
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
non
[Musique]
le soutien
vol spectaculaire réalisée par le pilote
de wingsuit sébastien alvarez équipé de
sa combinaison il a pu traverser le
cratère d'un volcan actif au sud de son
pays natal le chili personne avant lui
n'avait fait cela une manoeuvre très
délicate qui a nécessité un an de
préparation
c'est vraiment une petite station
familiale près de chez nous
si liliane voix de la chance